a typical day would be you know getting
up
probably having a drink you know whilst
getting ready
um
maybe a line maybe do you know what I
mean
um before I would go out to school
Nathan was just 13 years old when he
first started using drugs saving up
lunch money to buy crack and heroin
he's been clean for 17 months now but
wishes help could have been on hand much
sooner
it's only when you kind of break that
cycle and you look back and you think
actually that wasn't okay
um you know you're causing so much harm
to yourself and the other people that
have to witness that I think it's very
hard to pick on up on if you don't know
the signs um
but you know totally wish that there
would have been someone that knew those
signs and could have picked up on that
when it comes to young people drugs are
often associated with partying
but this is misleading many aren't using
for fun they're doing it to cope
new research shows there's been a 75
increase in young people using
substances to escape problems
and the total number of those taken
illegal drugs has doubled in the last
year to 2.6 million people that's one in
every 3 16 to 25 year old in the UK
a huge number of young people
um said that they were didn't seek
support 13 said they didn't seek support
because they were worried about how
people around them would react taking
drugs actually shouldn't have the taboo
and the stigma around it there's an
underlying reason for why young people
choose to do it and actually let's deal
with a tackle with that first
Nathan says addressing his mental health
issues was a huge part of his recovery
and for others currently battling
addiction getting access to Mental
Health Services needs to be just as easy
as getting access to drugs schmann
Freeman Powell Sky News